[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA ELLIOTT: So
actually, show of hands,
how many people have
heard of Kaggle?
OK, great.
How many have actually
participated in a competition
or done something on Kaggle?
OK, fewer hands, OK.
So Kaggle is the world's
largest data science community.
We are nearly 2 million, as
you might have caught wind
of in the keynote yesterday.
We span the globe.
So we have people coming from
all regions across the globe.
The community consists of people
from a variety of backgrounds,
not just data science
practitioners,
but hobbyists, researchers,
academics, and even software
engineers, and people
from all backgrounds.
So why are people
coming to Kaggle?
Why are there 2 million users?
Predominantly, we hear
it's for learning, sharing,
and practicing data science.
And they do that by
engaging with three products
on our platforms.
The first being
our competitions--
so this is what Kaggle
has traditionally
been most well-known for.
This is where companies
and organizations
host machine-learning problems.
Second is our
Kernels environment.
So this is our cloud-based
data science workbench.
People collaborate and
create code and notebooks
using their datasets.
And that brings me to our third
product which is Datasets.
So this is our
open data platform.
Currently, we're hosting about
nearly 9,000 public datasets
that people have uploaded to
share and use within their data
science projects.
So today, of course, because
I'm with the competitions team,
I am going to focus
on competitions.
And so what is a
Kaggle competition?
So Kaggle hosts supervised
machine-learning competitions.
And at any given time, you can
visit our competitions page
to see what is live.
This is actually a snapshot
from several months ago.
But I think it
gives a nice glimpse
at the variety and the
types of competitions
that we host from image
classification to forecasting.
And then, this over
here on the right,
is a snapshot of a
competition that we
had run with Porto Seguro
which is a Brazilian insurance
company.
Insurance companies
commonly run their use cases
in this type of an environment.
And so they were looking to
predict if a driver would
file a claim in the next year.
And so I'll use
Porto as an example
of what a competition is
and how it's structured.
So using that as an
example, the setup
is quite simple for a supervised
machine-learning competition.
We work with the
host who provides
a large labeled dataset with
a target variable to predict.
We work with our
data science team
to cleanse and prepare the
dataset for the platform.
And then we split it into a
training set and a test set.
So the training set
is what we provide
to competitors with the
labels or ground truth.
And that's what they
train their algorithms on
to generate predictions
against a test set.
And that test set is what we
use to evaluate and assess
the accuracy of the algorithms
that are being submitted.
And so using Porto
as an example,
if I grossly oversimplify
the data set,
perhaps they provided
training data,
including metadata on
drivers' age and income--
de-identified and anonymized
of course and then, of course,
the ground truth labels
of whether or not
the claim was filed.
So our competitors
join the competition,
they download the data,
they build their algorithms
and then submit predictions
against the test
set, where the target variables'
answers have been withheld.
We score the accuracy
of those predictions
based on an evaluation metric
and then rank those competitors
on a live leaderboard.
And so the
leaderboard ultimately
is what results in who
receives prize money sponsored
by the host of the competition.
And it's this
competitive dynamic
that really fuels
people's eagerness
to achieve and outpace one
another throughout the duration
of the competition.
And it's ultimately something
that we witness time and again
through looking at the
score progression over time
for any given competition.
So for Porto Seguro, we saw
that, over time, the score,
the highest leaderboard score,
converged on this asymptote
or what we consider to
be the maximum of what
is achievable on that
data set and that problem.
So now that I've
talked a little bit
about how the competitions
are set up and structured,
I want to bring that to life a
little bit and talk about some
of the common use
cases that we witness
customers running on Kaggle.
And so I'll talk about four
different use cases and then
how the businesses are gaining
value through running a Kaggle
competition.
So the first is
sales forecasting.
So Corporacion Favorita is
a leading Ecuadorean grocer.
They were looking to
better predict and forecast
sales of items in their stores.
So this is a classic
forecasting problem.
As you might imagine, retailers
need to get this right.
It affects inventory.
It affects staffing--
and especially
when you're dealing with
perishable items, where
the cost of shelf life
is even more important.
So Favorita provided a
series of very rich datasets
that included things
like store and item
metadata, promotional
activities, holidays and events
in Ecuador, even oil prices.
And then they threw
it at the community
and said, what can you
do to predict unit sales?
And of course, at the
end of the competition,
they were able to receive
the winning algorithms.
But one thing that
we actually find,
perhaps even more valuable
than the winning algorithms,
is actually the activity
that happens on our forums.
And so for every
competition, there
is a discussion
and a forum where
people are able to share ideas,
approaches that they're taking,
methods, techniques.
And at the end of the
competition, of course,
is their solutions.
So for this type
of a competition,
where it's a feature-rich
tabular dataset,
you saw people doing some
creative and clever feature
engineering.
But one revelation that
came about at the end
of the competition
was the discovery
of the use of WaveNet for
this type of a problem.
So WaveNet was
conceived by DeepMind,
traditionally was used for
taking raw audio waveforms
and then generating speech.
But competitors
found that applying
that type of convolutional
neural network, the WaveNet,
was actually a great
predictor of time series data.
And so they applied
it on this problem.
And many of the leading teams
were able to make advancements
in this regard.
So I'm using this as an example
to illustrate how people often
share breakthrough findings,
new packages, novel approaches
through Kaggle.
And I would even argue that,
sometimes, you can even
track the proliferation
of different types
of these new concepts through
their frequency and appearance
within Kaggle's forums.
So that's our first example.
Secondly, recommender
systems-- so
recommender systems,
very commonly approached
in machine learning.
For Airbnb, they were looking to
predict where a new user would
make their first booking.
And so the reason, actually,
why I'm using this example--
it wasn't necessarily for Airbnb
about the solutions, but really
about the approaches
and the people who
were attacking their problem.
And that was because they came
to us running a recruiting
competition.
And so what we find is that
people in our community, as
well as customers--
whether it's through
competitions, or jobs board,
or just forum chatter--
are really looking to raise
their profile within the data
science community.
And so we have countless
stories of people finding
their next job through
sharing progress
that they've made on Kaggle
or using their data science
projects as examples
in interviews.
And so the Airbnb
example is really
about a recruiting motivation.
Thirdly, I thought I'd touch
on another common and rapidly
rising use case in
machine learning,
which is natural
language processing.
So of course, with the advent
of things like Google Home
and Assistant,
we're seeing a lot
of Natural Language Processing
interest on our platform.
So Google's own Jigsaw team
was hosting a competition
to help identify and classify
toxic comments into, actually,
six different subclasses--
things like threats, hate,
obscenities, that sort of thing.
And their mission was to
really identify and almost get
ahead of negative
behaviors in order
to promote better online
conversations-- so a really
nice noble mission.
And the Jigsaw team
was actually very
interested in the
different approaches
that people were taking on
this newer area of study.
And the things that you
might expect out of NLP
like playing around with
embeddings, or language
normalization
preprocessing techniques,
neural networks of
course, and just
throwing as much as
they can at a problem.
And that's actually
something that we commonly
see in Kaggle competitions.
We call it a
kitchen sink method,
which is all the different
techniques that you
can throw at a problem--
what sticks, what works best,
what advances the problem more.
And as the title of
my session suggests,
when you have this largest
audience of community
members attacking a problem with
these brute force techniques,
you're bound to find
something that works.
And that's kind of how
problems like this advance.
And so one thing that
we see evidence of that
through our Kernels.
So for every
competition, there's
a discussion or a
forum, but there's
also a series of Kernels
that people have shared--
so that's code and notebooks
with, oftentimes, baseline
models.
And in this particular
competition,
there was actually quite
a lot of Kernels shared.
And the winning
algorithms tended
to be some blend of the
best techniques that
surfaced to the top.
Just an interesting anecdote
about this competition
is we did some
post-competition analysis
and discovered that any
algorithm that performed quite
well on one subtype, one of
those subclasses of toxicity,
actually performed quite well
across all of the subtypes.
So there wasn't necessarily
a specialist algorithm.
They performed well
across all subclasses,
which was quite interesting.
So the last area
that is, of course,
quite hot in machine learning
is image classification,
computer vision.
To date, our highest
prize pool competition
was hosted by the Department
of Homeland Security, TSA.
And so if you flew here,
or if you've ever flown,
you probably run
into these scanners.
And so what the
TSA is trying to do
is, of course, detect objects
that are cause for threats
and then cause for
secondary screening.
But of course, when people are
alarmed for non-threat objects,
so falsely alarmed, that
wastes people's time,
it causes stress, Sometimes,
people miss flights.
And so the TSA is trying to curb
those kind of false positives,
while at the same time, not
risking passenger safety
by missing real threats.
And so they provided a
really nice test dataset
of volunteers' scans
to mimic threat objects
and then had people
identify whether or not
there was an object in each of
the zones of a person's body.
And the images that
they used were actually
quite complex and large.
There were two
different formats.
There was a 3D format.
And then there was also a
2D cross-sectional format.
And rather than try to explain
to you the winning algorithms
and the techniques that
were used, which, of course,
you can go to our forums
and find out more about,
I thought I would use
this as an opportunity
to share the walks of life
and the diversity in the walks
of life that people
who win or participate
in these competitions come from.
So of course, you're
going to have your PhDs
or advanced degree
participants who specialize
in medical imaging,
have many years
of working with computer vision.
But interesting anecdote, within
our 10 winners, one of them
was actually a UC
Berkeley freshmen.
Another was someone who is
a data science practitioner,
but actually never
touched computer vision
and just wanted to work with
something really cool and foray
into computer vision.
And then lastly, we had a team
of just Kaggle enthusiasts.
They were data
science practitioners.
But they made-- I
don't want to say
a career-- but a hobby of
working on Kaggle competitions
and taking learnings from
their prior competitions
to feed into this
particular win.
And so we see that, from
across all our competitions,
across all our
participants, everyone
is converging to really share
and learn from one another
and especially in trending
areas like computer vision
where advanced techniques
might need to be employed.
That kind of got mixed up.
Ooh.
Sorry.
So I covered a few of
the classic use cases
for Kaggle competitions.
What I thought I'd talk about
now is where we're headed.
So where I'll start
with that story
is actually Kaggle's
broader vision.
So if you've come
to Kaggle lately,
and you're familiar
with our competitions,
you'll see that we've
introduced these other product
areas that I've touched
on previously, Kernels
and Datasets.
And so what we envision
to be is a home
for data science, a place where
people are not just playing,
but actually doing their
data science projects,
doing their work.
And we see that
happening by offering
a combination of a
rich community that's
ready to share and
learn, datasets
where you can do your work,
and then an environment where
people can create code,
reproducible code,
and collaborate on that code.
So we see competitions
moving in this direction
as well to leverage these
strengths that we are
building in a more genuine way.
And so where we're going to
do is towards this concept
of code competitions.
And so today, the
way I described
the way competitions
are set up today,
people are actually
submitting predictions
that their model is
generating-- models
that they're building
probably locally, maybe
in some cloud environments.
But what we envision is
that people can actually
submit their code.
And so we've run a
handful of these so far.
And we're building towards
offering more of these.
But an example of
this is a competition
that we ran hosted by Mercari.
And so they are an online
marketplace where people
sell their secondhand goods.
And so they were
looking to improve
the prediction of prices
that were suggested
to the sellers of those goods.
So what they do is they submit
their code within our Kaggle
Kernels environment.
They can collaborate
with teammates
by sharing that code with
those teammates privately.
And then, they submit the
actual code rather than just
the predictions to that code.
So what you can imagine
is that, for the customers
in the equation, they're
receiving the code that
was used to generate the
submissions in a more
reproducible environment.
They can also run that code
on a truly held-out test set.
And then, for our
community, they're
able to work in an environment
that enables them to truly
collaborate with one another.
And so this is all moving
towards our goal of really
being a place where
people can share and learn
from one another by creating an
environment for them to do so.
And so that is our
vision for where
we're headed in competitions.
So what I'd like to do
now is actually step you
through a live example
of a competition.
And so I'll start
my demo portion.
So this is our
Competition's listing page.
Any user-- you sign
up for an account,
you can get access to this.
What I thought I'd
do is just show you.
So this is just today, right--
the active competitions
we have going on.
We have a series of
featured competitions,
and these are the ones
that are typically
hosted by commercial
organizations or companies who
are looking to receive
the solutions for each
of the challenges.
They post what their
prize pool is as well
as the summary of what
they're trying to solve.
Below those, we have
a series of Getting
Started Competitions-- so
your classic MNIST and Titanic
competitions.
We refresh these so people
can continue to work on those
and learn, especially if
you're getting started.
And then, followed by a series
of research and playground
competitions-- so you
can see that a series
of these playground competitions
are using our new format
of code competitions.
So what I thought I'd do
is actually jump into--
this isn't necessarily
a featured competition.
But it's a competition we
launched about a week ago.
And it's being hosted by the
Inter-American Development
Bank.
And they are trying to improve
the prediction of poverty
levels within a country.
So in this case,
it's Costa Rica.
And they're doing
this because they
use that as a way to
assign social welfare need
and these types of programs--
when it loads.
OK.
So this is the live
competition site.
It gives a little
background of what
that host is trying to achieve.
It gives an overview
of the evaluation
metric we're using to
score the submissions.
And so we have a library of
these evaluation metrics.
And we work with the host
to identify what they're
trying to emphasize,
what they're
trying to de-emphasize in
order to come to an evaluation
metric that makes the most
sense for that problem.
We have prizes.
In this case, it's
just Kaggle swag.
This is considered a
for-good challenge,
and therefore, we're not
looking to award prize money.
And then timeline associated
at any important dates--
the data itself is accessible
through the competition's data
page.
And we've added
some new features.
The data, of course,
can only be downloaded
after you've accepted
the competition's rules.
And we have added a
new feature down here
around what we
call DataExplorer.
And it gives people a glimpse
at what the data for a given
dataset looks like.
And so you can
download that data
once you have accepted the
rules for the competition.
And then, you can use
it to train or test
your algorithm's
performance locally
or in a cloud environment.
As I mentioned before, there
are Kernels for the competition.
So these are completely
organically generated
by our community.
Oftentimes, they range from
exploratory data analyses--
so people looking at the
data and what features
appear to have some importance.
And both share
their notebooks that
do that type of
exploration and plots.
And then, within Kernels also
is, of course, some often basic
baseline models as well.
Our discussion pages
is where people
share anecdotes about the
approaches that they're taking,
the types of features that
they're trying to explore,
if they want to team
up on a competition,
and that sort of thing.
And then, the leaderboard is,
of course, the ongoing tally
of how people are performing.
Competitions typically
last two to three months.
And at the end of
the competition,
those in the winning spots
will receive the prizes.
The other thing that I thought
I'd share in this context
is an actual Kernel model.
So I'll do that, actually,
through another competition
that I can highlight we just
actually launched yesterday
because I know that we have
a starter Kernel that we've
created.
So for this particular
competition,
it's using, actually, a
public BigQuery dataset--
New York City Taxi data, which
includes the origination point
as well as the end point for a
bunch of different taxi fares
and then the corresponding
fare for that ride.
And so the idea is
to create models
that will predict what the fare
will be based on that data.
And so we just launched this
this morning, or last night.
And so we're still
gaining some teams here.
But we did create a Kernel that
uses a simple linear model.
And so you can see
what one of these
looks like that actually
generates a solution.
What he's done is he's
done a very basic look
at the distance
between the two points,
between the start and
end points and then
taking a look at using that as a
way to generate a model for how
to predict the fare.
And this type of a very
basic approach, I think,
gets him an RMSE value of--
so that's Root
Mean Squared Error,
which is the evaluation
metric used in this case.
So it'll get that RMSE value
of maybe around $5 or $6.
But what the competition
is hoping to help people do
is make advancements
using other techniques.
And actually, this was
hosted in coordination
with Coursera who is
offering a course that's
helping people use TensorFlow
to work on this type of problem.
And so what this does is it
generates an output submission
that can be used to be submitted
directly to a competition.
For sake of quickness,
I've gone ahead
and forked that same Kernel and
rerun it, commit it in order
to be able to show how you might
take the output of the Kernel
and then submit it to a
competition for evaluation.
And then, what that does is
that immediately generates
your score and then places
you on the leaderboard
for that competition.
So that's the summary of
how a competition works,
what we're doing, different
types of use cases
that we're solving
for customers.
OK.
Well, thank you all very much.
Have a good day.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]